Xaro completes one unit of work in five
hours this one unit of work can mean
anything writing code for an application
or making ten sandwiches or maybe
solving 20 questions in a quiz it can be
anything so with this given we have been
asked the amount of work she would
complete in two hours to solve this we
need to understand the relation between
time and work time multiplied by the
rate at which work is done gives us the
amount of work done it's similar to time
multiplied by speed gives us the
distance covered here the time
multiplied by the rate will give us the
work done Zarah works for five hours and
in that time frame she completes one
unit of work what will be the rate at
which she completes her work to find the
rate we simply transpose five hours to
the other side we get the rate as one
unit of work every 5 hours this is the
rate at which Sarah completes the work
coming back to the question how much of
the work could be completed by her in
two hours time multiplied by the rate
gives us the work done two hours
multiplied by 1 over five will give us
the work done in two hours it gives us 2
over five it implies that Zara completes
2/5 of the work in two hours or we can
say that Zara completes 40% of the work
in two hours this is the most basic
formula we will see in time and work
problems if you have gone through our
videos on time speed and distance you
would probably have thought of another
way to tackle this problem there are two
cases here first when she works for five
hours and second when she works for two
hours in both cases the rate is constant
her rate of work is one unit of work
every five hours it means that the time
and work are directly proportional in
the first case five times R is equal to
1 and in the second case she works for
two hours and the rate is constant five
is multiplied with two over five to get
two as the work done is directly
proportional to the time spent on doing
the work we also multiply this with two
over five one multiplied with
two over five will give us two over five
and that's our answer we use the direct
variation technique here you don't have
to use this technique but if you
understand it well you will be able to
tackle a lot of problems at warp speed
time and work problems get even more
interesting when two or more people work
together we will see a few more examples
in the coming sessions
[Music]